but when you look at me please tell me
you see that I have like a face right
[Music]
black mirror I am almost caught up I'm
gonna kind of miss not having more of
these to get to on the docket anymore
but well you know until there's a new
season but in any case men against fire
I am gonna cut right to the chase this
is right now competing with the Waldo
moment for my least favorite episode of
black mirror although for a different
reason in the case the Waldo moment that
was about the only one that I'd seen
where I felt like the idea wasn't fully
refined yet like the the script needed
one more revision things weren't quite
gelling at the level because you know
generally in black mirror or whatever
the idea is the writing is just at a
very high level and I just felt like the
Waldo moment wasn't quite there this one
it's different this one just was so
predictable and I mean like really I've
I've had there have been episodes of
this actually just the last one just San
Junipero I said that there was nothing
that happened in it that was
particularly surprising to me but the
thing is that's not necessarily a
requirement because if if it is written
at a high enough level it can still
impact you regardless actually I think
in a lot of ways that's a sign of truly
great writing because surprises are kind
of the easy way to make any emotion you
you give someone hit harder it's why
jump scares are in are in all the cheap
horror movies it's why really sudden
tragic deaths you know you know they get
the tear going for it if it's a surprise
it ups the the emotional impact but if
something can really get emotional
impact out of you even though it's not
all that surprising that really is a
sign of good writing it's a big part of
what I loved about San Junipero
in this case not only did nothing
surprise me it unlike seeing Junipero
this felt very much like it was
structured with the intention that stuff
was supposed to be surprising me so this
was a case where I felt really far ahead
of the story and that generally tends to
result in boredom ultimately the look I
I had the notion of almost everything
that was gonna happen and was gonna pan
out at 13 minutes into this movie if
this sounds really precise is because
when I had the thought process I
actually paused it and said how far into
this am I I'm like 13 minutes I'm like I
hope this has something this is gonna
sneak something in on me because
otherwise I figured out an hour long
piece of narrative 13 minutes in please
tell me I'm wrong and I wasn't and I
think maybe part of it is is that the I
think I think there were there were two
missteps I think the concept while good
in a sound would it's actually what I've
seen done before there was I think it
was an outer limits episode not original
series like one of the revival series
where there was something very similar I
think it was in a war and they had
soldiers on on drugs as ostensibly to to
keep them immune from disease that
caused them to see their enemy as
monsters
so that it was easier for them to kill
them so it's a concept I'd already seen
done and often times with black mirror
these are these are ideas that may be
the core of the idea I've seen done but
not the way in which it's handled and
and by that I mean a lot of black
mirrors themes are things that we've
seen handled before you know themes of
you know fear of dying fear of loss you
know the the deterioration of the mind
dependency on certain pieces of
technology or social aspects you know
these are all themes that I've seen done
elsewhere but I haven't seen
play out quite the way that they have in
the way black mirror tends to do when it
tackles them this I felt like I've
already seen it done and I've seen it
done in almost this precise way and the
other thing unfortunate is I think the
the episode tipped its hand very early
as well because when when stripe gets
his little heads-up display in his head
and he's sort of pointing his hand
through like oh look at that like that
was drawing too much attention to it and
again I maybe I've seen too many of
these things and by these things I mean
both black mirror episodes and you know
sci-fi twist stories in general but my
brain immediately went they would not be
drawing this much attention to this if
this was not gonna somehow play into the
twist and you know when there's all this
build-up to the roaches and we haven't
seen them yet
and I I was hoping that it was my
initial hope that the roaches were
actually gonna be some sort of even if
not piece of technology you know kind of
like the dogs in metal head then maybe
or some sort of weird technological
biological hybrid but when it turned out
just to be weird-looking humans my
immediate thought was the thing in his
eyes makes them look like that they're
normal people and so I called that so
early in the in the episode and then you
know I thought well maybe the the twist
is to why they're killing these
particular people that'll be interesting
and I don't want to knock that either
because I think it was left deliberately
vague which I think was one of the good
calls actually because you know when
when the guy is sort of telling him
about why these people have to die he's
basically talking about genetic purity
he's talking about people who have been
genetically screened and there are
health issues or mental issues or as he
called them sexual deviance ease so you
know anyone who's out there who is
or who cares about somebody who has a
mental illness has a physical condition
is not cisgender and heterosexual hi
uuugh that was the one moment it sort of
gave me that sinking gut feeling of my
god because just make them monsters make
it easy to wipe out people and and an
acknowledgement that yeah what we're
doing is awful and we're gonna do this
to make it easier that's that that was
sort of the one moment that conversation
he has with with his superior you know
in that interrogation room and also his
his ultimate choice his acceptance of
the lie that rings pretty true as well
and and the level it was taken to where
you know he goes back to this
dilapidated colorless empty home that he
sees as lush and beautiful and with a
wife who loves him who is not there so
like the very end it managed to get at
me a little bit but by that point I'd
spend so much of the episode just going
please tell me you've got something up
your sleeve besides just these are
people who don't look like people
because of the tech and it kind of
didn't so I think the problem was even
though by the end it it didn't win me
back completely by the end but by the
end it was doing stuff right and it was
doing stuff that was actually putting in
a bit of an impact that was that was
like that was like with ten minutes left
in the episode so the things about an
hour long so 13 minutes in I figured out
exactly what this going and how this is
gonna play out pretty much to the letter
the last 10 minutes are in no way
surprising or unexpected but are well
done but that leaves me with
almost 40 minutes in the middle that are
just me kind of going yeah yeah yeah I
know I know I know and it the other
thing is I it didn't help where the the
character he's seen the most with our
you know the no-nonsense Sargent type
and the trigger-happy sexually repressed
character which are both really well
trodden grounds and I don't I personally
am NOT of the opinion that making them
women as opposed to men with which they
would usually be in these kinds of
stories is not enough to make them
interesting
it makes them ever so slightly less of a
slog to watch because it shifts the
dynamic a little but functionally these
characters are identical to the kinds of
characters you always see in these sorts
of things I mean the in terms of
behavior the you know if I were to tell
you oh there's this military team and
here's the no-nonsense sergeant who
issues the orders the the that field
commander she acts exactly like you
would expect that to ask her if I said
oh you know there's one member of the
team was a little like yeah let's get in
there man that would have made me come
so hard and and stuff like that if I
told you that there was a character
acted like that she acts exactly like
that making her a woman alone is not
enough to suddenly make this an
interesting character as opposed to an
archetype so yeah it just it it pulled
together some impactful stuff at the
very end but it wasn't enough because I
was kind of slogging through it up to
that point which is a first for black
mare I've never felt like an episode was
a slog before but this one kind of was
and like I said I don't know if I like
this less than the Waldo moment or if I
like the Waldo moment a little bit
better because their problems are very
different so
I don't know if I ever do a total
ranking it's the bottom is probably
gonna be these two battling it out but I
will say that I think maybe if black
mirror is your primary sci-fi twisty
kind of scary future tech what will it
mean show and this is like the only one
you watch maybe it would have worked
better for you because if I hadn't seen
that Outer Limits episode I think it was
at her limits I could be completely
wrong about that but if I hadn't seen an
episode of something that was basically
this exact same premise maybe I wouldn't
have gotten so far ahead of it I think I
probably would have figured it out
pretty well ahead of when it was but
maybe not as early as I did so maybe if
other folks you know haven't seen so
much of this stuff that they can guess
these things as early as I did and I'm
not saying that as a bragging thing I'm
not proud of that that annoyed me it
detracted from my my viewing experience
but how did it how did it work for you
men against fire what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do I can be supported on page you're on
it got a Twitter I got a podcast I got
t-shirts for sale links for all that
stuff and more is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]